-Our first guest tonight
is an Emmy-nominated
and Golden Globe
award-winning actress
for her work on the hit series
"Black-ish."
The eighth and final season
airs Tuesday nights, on ABC.
Let's take a look.
-How was your first day
at the clinic?
What?!
-So fulfilling.
-We met so many different
kinds of people
with such incredible stories.
-See?
Oh, gosh, you guys get it.
-Thank you for the opportunity.
-No, thank you.
Are you kidding me?
So, same time next week?
-Oh. You want us
to do this again next week?
-Uh, yeah.
Not in a, like,
"I'm making you do it"
kind of way.
This is, like, a fun thing
for us to do together.
-Oh!
So, this was optional?
-Yeah.
-See, Vanessa? I told you.
-[ Chuckles nervously ]
-She thought we had to come
since you're, like,
our boss and all.
-Oh, so -- so you guys are only
here because I'm your boss?
-Oh, I'm so glad you get it.
A lot of people
would not be cool with that.
-Please welcome back to the show
our good friend
Tracee Ellis Ross.
How are you, Tracee?
-Hi, Seth!
I want to make an entrance
like it's real,
but you're not
gonna see my face.
But the dress is so good.
Watch. Here we go.
-It's beautiful.
Oh, thank you!
It is a beautiful dress.
It is a beautiful color.
Let me tell you something.
Nobody wears bolder
and more beautiful colors
than Tracee Ellis Ross.
Consistently.
-I love a color, I love a color,
I love a color.
Hi, Seth.
How you doing?
We're back at home.
What is this?
-I know. I'm sorry
to flip the script on you.
I promise, next time,
it'll be in person.
And, you know,
I'm a little worried.
I want to get your assurances
that even though "Black-ish"
is coming to a close,
you will continue to be
one of our favorite guests on
the show in the years to come.
-You are assured.
And you don't have to apologize.
Seth, I also shut myself down.
Not because I got delta --
got delta --
got omicron --
I can't even keep it together.
Not because I got it,
but because I got scared again,
and everything's
just back at home.
It just is what it is.
-Yeah.
I mean, for the easily scared,
this has been a real
return behind the doors.
-Let me tell you something,
I'm back at home by myself.
[ Both laugh ]
-Well, congratulations.
Congratulations on eight seasons
of the show.
Congratulations on a premiere
that had, let's be honest,
one of the toughest gets
for a sitcom guest star
you could imagine.
You guys got Michelle Obama.
-Yeah, called up my friend,
texted her, and said,
"Hey, you want to come on down,
do a little guest spot
on the show?
You know,
just you got a little time,
just come on over and visit."
Yeah, it was really exciting.
What a way to start
a final season.
She is the --
And she's such a great actress.
-Yeah.
-She was so good at improv
and just kind of
hanging with us.
So that was a really fun way to
start our final farewell season.
-So, you will confirm
that you did not make her
audition for this part.
This was an offer-only
situation.
-Oh, no, she auditioned, yeah.
Actually, it was funny --
I had Barack audition for her.
And then, once he made it
through the first round,
I was like,
"All right, we'll see the wife."
[ Laughs ]
-Interesting.
And so now, in the end,
Barack didn't get the part?
-No. As a matter of fact,
it's funny you say that.
He did not.
And -- But it turned out well.
It turned out really well.
No, they're amazing,
and, no, they did not audition.
As a matter of fact,
we auditioned for them.
We had to make sure they knew
we were up to par.
-Now, your producers
were aware of the fact
that you were friends
with Michelle.
Did they wait a full eight years
before asking you,
or has this been something
that you've had
to put them off
over each season?
-They did not wait eight years,
but this was the first time
I was willing to ask.
-All right, perfect.
Well, it did work out perfectly.
Your sense of timing
was impeccable.
-Thank you.
It's not normally the case,
but I'll take it on this one.
[ Laughs ]
-So, what --
When you look back at a show
that's been on this long,
what are the things
that you feel like
have changed the most
or the things that
you've enjoyed watching mature
over the last eight years?
-The truth is, the most
important part of the show,
for me, and the joy and pride
really all comes from watching
Anthony's facial hair grow.
-Yeah, good.
-Some would think that it is,
you know,
the extraordinary experience
of witnessing and being --
participating in the growth
of the children on the show.
Or maybe even -- Look at this.
-That's amazing.
-This is how I know
time has passed.
The robustness
of Anthony Anderson's beard
showed us that, truly, anyone
cannot achieve what he achieved.
-I think it showed
we all have room to grow.
We all have room to grow.
-That is exactly
what it tells us.
But I'm also left
with a lot of joy and pride,
'cause, you know,
we did some good work, Seth.
-You did.
-It feels like we did
some good stuff, yeah.
-You mentioned the kids.
And you know,
I have many writers on my show
who are younger than me --
I would say,
almost all of them --
but they're not children.
But you actually worked
with kids.
Like, cool, plugged into
pop culture, the young people.
Was that helpful, in that it
made you feel young,
or depressing
because it made you feel old?
-It was devastating, Seth.
It's something that I'm still
in therapy because of.
I entered the show and walked
around mostly, on most days,
considering myself quite cool.
-Yeah.
-You know, youngish,
so to speak.
-Mm-hmm.
-But, no, the children
on the show, I think they
actually played a lot of games
and would turn to me
to kind of ask me questions
just so that they could
laugh hysterically
about the things I did not know.
And then, I would explain
to them that, like,
it's their job
to keep me up to speed.
So my failure as a cool person
is on them.
They have to be accountable
for that,
which they also thought
was funny.
But you know what gets sad,
Seth, is when you're actually
trying to convince someone
how cool you are.
-Yeah.
-It's depressing.
-Well, let me tell you,
you bring me on that set,
'cause we hung out 20 years ago
in New York City,
you and I, Tracee.
We ran this town!
We ran this city.
-You have no idea!
You have no idea the places
I've been, the people I've seen,
and the things I know!
-Now, a lot of those nightclubs
are closed now.
They're cycling clubs now.
-Yes, yes.
-Spin classes happen there.
I have more questions for you.
And in the time --
in this commercial break,
I would just invite you,
as I will do,
to reflect on our youth.
We'll be right back with more
from Tracee Ellis Ross.